[Music]
Kim Kardashian and Kylie Jenner are
totally twinning before Kim changes five
more times in one day I love that
check out the sisters in Calabasas on
Monday both rockin gold aviators tiny
t's tight spandex and yeah heeled sock
boots she is the best you know she's my
little twin soul the same day Kim
changed an additional five times for a
mysterious photoshoot first check out
the 37 year old in this silver spandex
number paired with thigh high boots and
a darker gray puffer jacket she swapped
accessories in this look ditching the
ski coat and adding a seat belts like
belts around her waist silver seems to
be a theme she also opted for this super
similar look but with a cropped
long-sleeve top and suede thigh high
boots I want to wear things that make me
feel good about myself
Kim also changed into this red spandex
look complete with matching sunglasses
and black leggings underneath and
finally she ditched the spandex for this
head-to-toe Orange sweat suit outfits
with again no boots I love that the last
few years I've been able to just wear
sweats and heels and
so comfortable no word on what shoot
required Kim to change so many times but
fans think it might be for Kanye's next
easy collection so we'll just have to
wait and see
right
[Music]